hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's time for the Monday Morning podcast
for Monday January first
2024 another year pasted oh gez I'm
recording this the last
um last day of 2023 the first 15 minutes
he going to be the last day of 2023 and
then I'm recording the rest of this
after the Rose Bowl cuz I'm going to go
see the Michigan Wolverines against the
Alabama Crimson
Tide um really looking forward to that
um I know Michigan's going to try to
steal some signals but I think Alabama's
okay considering they hired their
linebackers Michigan's linebackers coach
from 21 and 22 for one month you know
just to shoot the
breeze uh we'll see how that goes now I
am turning over a new Leaf oh gee y
y um I am done
screaming about the prevent
defense I am now just gonna I'm just
going to approach it because I've yet to
get a [__] answer how anybody can
explain to me the purpose I understand
what the purpose is the purpose is you
give up the middle of the field you keep
the ball in play and by the time you get
down there they're going to run out the
clock
and I just I I'm not a math guy gee what
a surprise I'm not a reading guy I'm
barely a guy all right I don't [__]
in my
lifetime Oh Billy old face here I have
seen so much [__] come and go in the NFL
because it just doesn't work okay there
used to be a position in the NFL called
the flanker I never really knew what he
did but it's gone flanker [__] aged
out that changed I remember all the time
they'd call Double reverses you never
see that anymore Statue liberty play you
don't [__] see that anymore all the
quarterbacks were white you don't see
that there was white
cornerbacks they used to be star running
backs that would get [__] 1,800 yards
you had to get like 1500 yards if you
going to [__] win the rushing title
right and everybody like the the whole
half the [__] League had a thousand
yard all of that [__] the game changed
the rules changed and [__] that used to
work didn't the wishbone offense and
college football nobody [__] runs
that anymore maybe maybe division three
team because it just doesn't work
anymore but the one thing that just
stays since the 19 [__] 80s is the
prevent defense and I just don't get it
okay now I'm not going to lose my [__] I
bet on the Cowboys and the Cowboys won
and they
covered
okay there was like a minute change left
in the [__] game they're in field
goal
position it's first down the Lions have
no more timeouts what do they do they
throw the [__] ball I get it they're
going for the kill shot they don't get
it it's incomplete second down
incomplete stops the clock gives the
Lions a timeout then they run the ball
then they kick the ball for a field goal
so now they're up seven now they could
have run off another 30 40 [__]
seconds but instead they gave the Lions
40 something
seconds okay they kicked the [__]
ball to him they've been covering their
receivers the whole game they've been
playing great defense the whole game
okay the [__] score is 20-13 they've
only scored 13
points there's a minute 40 something
left for whatever [__] reason they go
into this soft Zone whatever the [__]
you call give him a 15 yard cushion now
I'm not good at math here but it's 10
yards for a first [__] down so every
throw was a first down like a 25 y a 10
y a 15 [__] yard and they go right
down the field the [__] game was over
should have been over next thing you
know Joe Buck has gone up another octave
going and the Lions is still in it and
I'm sitting there like going what the
[__] am I watching right now what is the
game plan here so they let the Lions
just wal down the [__] field I will
give them this they did keep them in
bounds as far as I
remember then they get into the Red Zone
and then they decide now we're going to
play [__] defense we're gonna give
you 60 [__]
yards and then now we're going to give
you four shots at the [__] End Zone
which they didn't even
need they didn't even need they threw it
underneath off to the right right and
then this kid Speedy McGill cut he
[__] dives into the endone
touchdown so now I'm sitting there go I
figure what the [__] spread was that
I have it was like three and a half or
four and I am like home alone like mcau
culin
screaming at my TV like I'm watching The
[Laughter]
Apocalypse I'm like what in the [__]
what did I just watch what the [__] am I
watching so then the Rams the Rams the
Lions [__] what's his face Dan uh the
that coach former player who played on
the Owen 16 Lions he's like oh no
[__] we ain't doing that again
this is the new lines we're going for
two so I'm thinking to myself the only
shot I have at winning this bet is if
this [__] kicks the extra point
we go into overtime and somehow the
[__] Cowboys shake off [__] up the
game score a touchdown and then I can
win my bet and this guy is going for two
gotta love that he's like [__] you
Dallas I'm going for
two I know you guys saw this but I just
have to work my way through this again
to [__] believe what I
saw [__] hike the ball this
scrambling around blah blah he throws it
to an offensive lineman two-point
conversion now it's 2120 with like
[__] 20 seconds left the [__] game
is over unless the Lions go into an 80
yard [__] cushion and just give him a
touchdown Which at this point I wouldn't
put past
anybody and then all of a sudden the
refs start [__] talking baba Baba B
boo they say the guy doesn't check in
and then they have footage of the
[__] guy shooting the
[__] with the
referee I guess he wasn't listening to
him I don't know what he was doing he
was acting like he was his [__] wife
saying what he wanted him to do that
Saturday I got it I got it yeah what
whatever so they said the [__] guy
was ineligible and they have all this
footage of the guy talking to the
[__] ref so now it's 2019 the Lions
it's back to 2019 the [__] Lions get
a
penalty I love that I'm laughing about
it now this is the new me cuz I I had to
leave my house cuz my kids came home
right in the end of course you know it
was like ENT trapment I was [__]
cleaned up the house Dad of the [__]
year and all they hear coming up the
house is like what the [__] are they
do probably worse than
that so my wife comes in and I get the
look right I get the look like if you're
in a band and you try to fill and you
[__] it up and the Rhythm guitarist the
Malcolm Young just looks over his
shoulder and you're like I'm going to
hear about that one right except this
was an fbm so now they whatever that
penalty is five yards or whatever so now
they're back on like their [__] 10
yard line or something like that and uh
Lions coach is like [__]
you he was like Joe pesy when he was
playing
Blackjack stick this card up you [__]
ass stick that ineligible penalty up
your mother's ass we're going for like
this guy's a [__] lunatic right he
goes for it they don't [__] get it
and I was just like so not only the
Lions not win I don't [__] cover and
I'm sitting there going how in the [__]
does he go for it again he was literally
like a degenerate Gambler at a CRA at a
[__] blackjack table at 3 in the
morning like [__] it I'm gonna I got
another grand I'm either going to leave
with 10 grand I just lose my final
[__] thousand bucks
um I don't
understand any of
that if anybody can explain to me how
about when of you [__] math nerds you
not football people that are [__]
good with with numbers explain to
me like because as far honestly I'm not
saying the
prevent never works but it seems to me
what it does is you're basically
guaranteeing the other team is going to
go down to the Red Zone and get four
chances at throwing a
touchdown
so I know the big controversy was that
the lineman the lions are saying checked
in he was definitely I don't know what
as Andrew Themis hilariously said was he
asking him how his Christmas was he was
talking to him I don't know what
happened but that's like the big
controversy of the game nobody is saying
why in the [__] what would why did you
play that soft the defense you were
acting like Jared gof was killing you
all day and that he had three Randy
mosses and Tony Gonzalez at [__]
tight end to throw to I'm not saying
they don't have talent in those
positions but like where they sit there
and they be like well you know you throw
a 5050 ball it could be [__] pass
interference yeah that could happen the
whole game that could happen the whole
[__] game it's like all of a sudden
everybody gets scared at the end of the
game it's like your defense was [__]
stopping them just keep playing defense
they have no [__]
timeouts okay let's say they get a
couple of first downs the [__]
clock's going to run out unless you're
giving them such giant chunks of
yardage I I'm just I'm just going to
sound like a broken record um I just
literally had to get this off of my
chest
before you know I go to the Rose Bowl
tomorrow which is today when you're
listening to this God willing unless
something unfortunate happened to me at
the
game this is my final 11 minutes of
podcasting
um yeah yeah I got this new thing that
where I watch sports and I'm just like I
have aged out of watching sports I'm
still going to watch them I don't
understand them um and it's happened to
me in all sports I don't understand why
in NBA basketball the 3 second rule also
applies to the offensive player he also
has to clear out fine so he has to clear
out and then I watch a guy dunk on
nobody and then scream like he's in 300
like he he just [__] dunked on Moses
Malone or something Moses isn't there
anymore Moses is over by the [__]
bench waiting to catch an outlet pass so
he can dribble it past the half court
line and pull up for a [__] 100 foot
three-pointer which inexplicably will go
in that's the one thing I do like about
the NBA it's the it's the greatest
collection of outside shooters ever the
level the percentage of shooting it's is
is far
superior to what it was when I was
watching in the game growing up but when
you dunked on when you dunked you had to
dunk on somebody it wasn't this [__]
t-ball [__] right or guys clearing out
because they don't want to get on Sports
Center um and then
hockey I watched hockey
2019 after 10 years of getting enforcers
out of the league the Boston Bruins show
up in the
finals with a in the final with a with a
[__] finesse
team no more sha Thorton no more [__]
liches
right and we lose to the blues who are
inexplicably allowed to play Old School
Boston Bruins hockey and I'm like what
the this was penalized all year except
now when it [__]
counts mean hey God bless St Louis they
got it I I don't understand
it all right I don't understand why
stealing signs is
illegal I don't care what technology
you're doing it's still [__]
unbelievably difficult and
maybe you you know what they're doing on
one or two plays that gives you
Competitive Edge but does that make you
win the game no they're not over there
saying what the [__] they're doing
they're still disguising it so it's
still an unbelievable skill I don't know
if you've ever looked it they're
covering their lips they got all these
crazy pictures and everybody's [__]
voguing you how the [__] do you even
figure out two plays one play all right
um but you can hire reformer coach just
for a month-long
contract for him to sit there and tell
bedtime stories about the other team's
Playbook and evidently that
is that is
okay
um you can crowd the plate in baseball
and you can go up there like you're GNA
go like you're going to Medieval Times
elbow pad Shin pad [__] a guard
around your jaw
you can hang out over the plate and then
if the [__] guy throws at
you uh you're allowed to have a [__]
temper tantrum and then they throw the
[__] pitcher out of the
game you can hit a home run and stand
there and admire it and flip the bat
like you just reinvented baseball and
nobody can throw it your head the next
time or they get [__]
suspended don't understand that how many
sports we got left what is left now that
was baseball football hockey basketball
I think I went to all of them
right
yeah I don't get it and guess what I
finally realized that nobody
cares so all I'm GNA do now when I watch
sports when something like that happens
is I'm just going to try to glance over
at somebody else who's also my age and
just just try to get a similar look from
them like does that make it good that
didn't make sense to you either okay
fantastic fantastic so
um
anyway this is the big thing in my life
I'm going to the Rose Bowl I'm taking my
new
truck uh over there I got the the Flatt
top
grill and I went out and I bought some
ratchet
straps U which I'd never used before
they're really [__] easy underrated
ratchet all right I'm back I am back
holy
[__] holy [__] what a game what a game
between twostory franchises
and I actually thought I was going to go
to that game be out in the elements from
s in the [__] morning until 7 at
night and I was going to come home and
just bang out the last 40 minutes of
this podcast what the [__] was I
thinking I was spent after that game a
glorious glorious afternoon of
tailgating morning afternoon of
tailgating an unbelievable game might be
the um one of the best sporting events I
ever went to even though it was kind of
a sloppy game a lot of mistakes made by
Michigan unforced errors and I thought
Alabama didn't quite play their past
football either but it was just the fact
that it was Michigan vers
Alabama
um Harbaugh vers Nick Sabin I just know
in 20 years those that's going to be two
cool coaches to talk
about um and just seeing like the
different fan bases was [__]
great um you know the Midwest accent you
know oh get some half and
half that [__] yeah that mixed with the
Alabama fans who
um most of them are cool but like this
this upper echelon of them
you know like the uh the pretty girls
you know they wear like the mini skirts
with the cowboy boots and then like the
guys dress like they look like they're
in The Truman Show it's like this guy
had like a sweater vest on with a polo
shirt and like khaki
pants I mean he looked like he was going
to like his sophomore semi-formal and
he's going to like a football game you
know brown hair perfectly parted like
just just a level of white that I can't
even relate to and I remember just
looking I was joking with a buddy of
mine and I saw the like like the the the
perfect chick he was with and I just
saying to my bud I go how psyched were
her parents when he came walking up the
walk I mean it was
uh it was a sight to behold it was like
literally like remember uh what was it
Trading Places and he stepped on the
ball like literally that
level where you you know you hear about
it but you said like those kinds of
white people don't exist do they and
then you go and like there they are
those are the ones they're talking
about I'm not going to lie to you as a
white person I was fascinated by it I
was like I you know and a little envious
I be like might be
[__] that could be cool to be that
white you
know [__] wearing a sweater
vest just not questioning [__] I mean
it's got to be like there's a level of
bliss to that um anyway so let me just
take you through the whole day I got
over my buddy's house at 7 7 in the
morning and then we we were waiting for
two there was three other car loads of
people right three other cars everybody
showed up 658 659 7:00 we were there
[__] military right we load up the
back of my truck TR um making her maiden
voyage to the Rose
bow um and then my buddy you know he
knew how to go in he just took all back
roads there was the easiest way I've
ever gotten in no traffic no wow they
closed off the street ah [__] we I
[__] how the [__] do we get in you
know I usually deal with that I usually
have like two or three meltdowns before
I go there most of that has to do with
me not the Pasadena Police Department so
we pull in as we're pulling in you
know one of the guys that's like guiding
you where you're supposed to go he goes
hey beautiful truck and I was like thank
you very excited so I
um you know we we get this great Spot
Great location mostly Michigan fans some
Alabama you know which was kind of how
the stadium was I felt like it was sort
of 6040 65
35 and um you know we post up got the
flat trop Grill immediately Crank That
Thing Up get that thing going and I
brought my coffee maker and uh which was
fantastic because I got to use the
three-prong Outlet in the tail in the in
the in the bed I found out you had to
have the truck on and I was thinking
like Jesus Christ I'm like I'm going be
like smelling this exhaust or whatever
but I don't know we were outside I
couldn't smell it maybe because I don't
know if diesel Burns a little cleaner
maybe I'm just [__] old I couldn't
smell it right so I start making
cappuccinos and
uh like we had people from other
tailgates were just come walking over
you guys got a coffee
[Laughter]
maker that's the worst you know when
you're next to people that didn't
[__] you
know you like there's there's a thing
where if you have a really good tailgate
you also got to kind of be a little
Incognito because all the Bears start
[__] wandering over you know trying
to [__] stick their nose in the
picnic basket I felt bad these guys kept
coming over going like wow man those
Burgers look good these guys were really
cool but we only brought we I don't I've
I've always had extra food but we
brought like the perfect amount where
everyone could only have one Burger but
uh we had a bunch of breakfast sandwich
we had breakfast sandwiches
going um we had was very basic and it
actually ended up making it work but we
had like insane apparat
so I was making [__] cappuccinos the
secret to my coffee is uh is the uh
filtered water I only use totally
filtered pure water and uh I think that
that makes all the difference as far as
it making it really smooth and not like
overly acidic and um the first 40
minutes of the tailgate I was [__]
Billy Barista over here made like 10
cappuccinos and I had a [__] blast
doing it and I actually was like I got
to the point where my foam was getting
you know my you know my milk I was
getting it to a temperature cuz I never
quite figured out how I could start
making like designs so what H what
happens with mine is I usually it's
right at the end I can make
something instead of right from the jump
the way I watch these Pros do it and
then what happens is it's a small window
and then it's just foam and it [__] the
whole thing up um but after doing like
10 in a row and sort of experimenting
with amount of milk amount of air how
long I kept it underneath the steam uh I
was starting to get a much better
consistency so I was kind of really
excited about that but you know it's the
best dude you know when you're a cookout
and you're making something and people
are complimenting you it's just the best
so everyone was like oh my God this is
[__] delicious and all of that stuff
and um I was the Martyr you know I
didn't I didn't make myself a cup of
coffee until the last one we were almost
out of milk and and uh and right as I
finished my
coffee uh my buddy Mike was bringing the
first breakfast
sandwiches like off the grill and I had
a bacon egg and cheese on an English
muffin with a cappuccino sitting on a
golf course on a [__] Fairway with
all of my friends getting ready to watch
Michigan and Alabama two storied
franchises going at it and I'm not going
to lie to you I had some dread
because every time I've gone to an
Alabama game Alabama has won um they
just [__] they're amazing Nick
sabin's [__] amazing you just got to
give it up to them they're [__]
amazing so you know I saw that I went to
LSU
um back uh who the [__] was there the
guy who ate the grass was still coach
coaching them Death
Valley
um again with an L I'm thinking Lane
kein that's
Mississippi uh anyways Les Meyers right
that guy was coaching up against Sabin
and I remember the whole student section
chanting [__] you Sabin [__] you Sabin
because he left LSU I think he went to
Miami went to the pros for a second and
then went back down took over Alabama
and basically is starting to make people
forget about Bear Bryant
um or is at least on the same level he
has to be
so anyway I'm sitting there with like
Dread because I went to that LSU game
and they had them they were balling out
and they were just [__] winning and
then they just started playing
conservative and Alabama never stopped
[__] playing which is something I
noticed about them they just keep
[__] they keep the pressure on they
don't go into a prevent defense they
keep [__] going after you right so um
then I saw him um Johnny Manzel Johnny
football college station the year
after he led the aies to beat him in uh
Tuscaloosa I saw the college station one
and they were [__] you know
just destroy not destroying but they
were they were controlling the game
Texas A&M did and then halftime came and
Nick sabin's [__] goddamn genius mind
oh is this what they're doing we're
going to do that we're going to do this
and then they just they just [__]
suffocated him in the second half I'll
tell you that LSU Stadium that was the
quietest Stadium I ever walked out of
after they lost to Alabama it was
[__] brutal it was pandemonium like
oh my God they're going to do it they're
going to do it and then they just
[__] pulled our legs right out from
underneath us it was it was Death Valley
deathly quiet is what it was and then I
saw this one doesn't count I saw Alabama
um in Alabama in like September some
cupcake cupcake game and that was never
a game so I was thinking
like you know I was thinking one of two
things Alabama's going to jump out early
or or Michigan's going to [__] look
like they're going to win it and
Alabama's just going to come back
because it's just what the [__] they do
it's just what the [__] they do that's
what's so frustrating about rooting
against them it's the same frustration
when I was rooting against Lewis
Hamilton and Mercedes all of those
years um you know because I can't do
that I can't just jump into a sport and
just pile on with the best [__]
person you got to go for an underdog
right
and they just you know operating at a
level of Excellence that other people
people
can't keep up with and it's
frustrating so anyway so we're sitting
at the tailgate we have our breakfast
sandwiches and then I have like uh I
have a cigar right and we're smoking
cigars and we're sitting there in the
chairs and uh sun's coming down it feels
great I'm looking at my truck I'm
[__] looks
beautiful uh I got that caffeine in me
you know a little bit of tobacco getting
catching my you know my sober Buzz that
I do here and uh as we're smoking cigars
these Alabama fans the regular looking
ones not the uh any stupped on the ball
those ones right the regular ones not
the ones who are going to be a [__]
Senator someday um they came walking by
and I heard one of the kids say to the
other kid goes uh yeah they're getting
the cigars out of the way early and I
didn't get it at first and I was like oh
he's saying we're going to have nothing
to celebrate afterwards and I was going
[__] and I'm thinking like he's
probably right everybody here is saying
Michigan everybody thinks Michigan is
going to [__] dominate so anyway long
story
short we have some
burgers um throw the football around and
just have a great [__] time and just
could feel it you knew it was going to
be a [__] good game so I got six
tickets four of them are in my Apple
wallet and then the other one is on this
other app that I had to [__] download
and I didn't I don't know where I was
supposed to put it but like I can't get
on Wi-Fi cuz I'm standing next to
990,000 other people also using the same
same satellite so there was this big
[__] thing as you were trying to go
in it was hilarious it was like all the
young kids were were good to go like
there was some young kid Alabama fan
helped me find my four tickets in the
Apple wallet how to get to it and uh I
thanked them and everything and then the
other [__] I had to
like I got four of us through and then
bartnik and Frasier I couldn't get
through I'm like I have the tickets and
then I had to wait till somebody came
over gave me like a Wi-Fi and I'm
standing there next to this
satellite [__] antenna with like five
other like you know Geico dads all the
young people just just rolling through
was all people like in my generation
were like I can't get the don't where
the tickets are right so then we finally
ended up getting and we get bartnik in
it's a bit of a journey getting to our
seats um some bathroom flooded or
something like that and uh there was
water pouring out and [__] so yeah I had
to throw out those sneakers uh we just
trudging through water that was coming
out of a bathroom I'm like that's the
water to flush the [__] down right not
the water that was flushing [__] down I
mean I didn't see any I don't know
whatever we'll just fast forward through
that awfulness but you know that's what
happens when you go to a stadium that's
[__] over a hundred years old so then
we end up getting to our seats and uh
Alabama wins the toss they defer to the
second half here we go you know stealth
bomber flies over the whole [__]
thing we made it there for
kickoff and
uh first play from scrimmage throw
Michigan's guy rolls out throws it right
to Alabama's Defender interception
they're going [__] nuts and I I just
sat down going like did I just how much
money did I just waste buying these
[__] tickets because it's just it you
throw I mean you're playing Alabama in
the [__] Rose Bowl in a playoff your
first [__] play for scrimmage you
throw an interception the [__] game's
over this is what you're bringing
against [__] Sabin and Alabama the
[__] game's over fortunately the guy
was ruled out of
bounds I was like all right thank God
for that and then they came back and
they were running the ball moving it
fine or whatever they may have a three
and out but whatever the whole first
half basically Michigan dominated it
with yardage time of possession and all
that sacking their quarterback like
three times they couldn't run the ball
michigans running the ball down their
throats but Mich keeps making these
[__] mistakes fumbling a
punt uh you know scoring a touchdown the
extra point the the [__] they hike
the ball back to the place kicker it
doesn't even get off the
ground miss an extra point so instead of
being like you know they're up 14 to
nothing or 14 to3 they give him a short
field on you know the fumbled punt they
score a touchdown on
that so at one point we're down 7even to
three by at at halftime it's 13 to to 10
and you're looking at the numbers going
like they should be up 173 147 there
should be a bit of a cushion here and
I'm just sitting there going like this
is what happens and now sabin's going to
go in during halftime and this game is
going to [__] turn on its head and
everything that Michigan's doing
Alabama's going to be doing except
they're going to be turning these drives
into [__] seven points
and you know I was there with my brother
and he knows all of this [__] he was
just going like yep we're going to have
to deal with two drives and then we're
going to have to adjust to what they're
doing but he was saying like we're going
to have to take a few hits here and he
was 100% right they [__] came out
like Gang Busters was it was like both
teams changed uniforms then Alabama can
do no wrong and Michigan
continues to you know be making mistakes
and and Alabama's players are jumping up
and down they're getting amped they're
getting into the game and all of that
and I'm just sitting there going like is
this going to [__] happen again
really I wasn't even saying that I was
like it's going to happen it's [__]
Nick
Sabin best in the business right
so um what ends up happening uh yeah
they basically they're up by
seven they're up by [__] seven we get
the ball back and I'm just like you know
I don't have any positive thoughts here
I'm just thinking like they're not going
to do it and then they just start
driving and they go right down the
[__]
field and and uh I don't even remember I
I can't remember what the [__] happened
everybody was just screaming they score
a
touchdown and I'm like are they going to
go for two are they going to go Dan
Campbell on this [__] are they going to
go for two here and they bring out the
place
kicker
and I'm immediately thinking like what
would what would have happened if they
didn't miss that extra point well
probably some different [__] would have
happened so they tie it up go into
overtime [__] Alabama wins the
toss they must have gotten the ball I
guess we stopped
them and then we drive down the
field score a touchdown everybody's
going crazy but then Alabama gets the
ball back and I'm and I'm just going
they're going to score a touchdown this
is it's not going to be this [__]
easy they go you
know we get him on fourth down or third
down was it break off a big run right
down to the two yard line I'm like all
right I think going to punch it in on
fourth down and they called that QB draw
one too many times Michigan was finally
ready for it and they stuffed him
and the place goes crazy and I was still
looking at the scoreboard just to double
check that that was fourth down and it
was [__]
over and
um all of a sudden they start shooting
off the fireworks and all of that and we
are just going
absolutely [__] nuts I cannot believe
it I can't believe it we see the
Michigan Wolverines beat Alabama and
Nick sabbin in a [__] playoff game in
overtime it was incredible I'm not going
to lie to you it was a [__] sloppy
game it was a sloppy game and uh those
[__] refs man they missed you know I
want to see that number 44 in Michigan
what the what the um unnecessary
roughness thing that he did versus when
you know this Michigan player you know
wide receiver and and and uh cornerback
were sort of battling each other
and the Alabama guy grabbed the Michigan
guy by his helmet and just threw him
down on the ground well after the play
was over in front of two
officials the whole stadium saw it
nothing no flag and then there was
another one when they the Michigan
quarterback um was running out of bounds
and the guy threw him down on the ground
out of bounds
nothing and I also thought their spots
were very generous but I mean I'm also
was like really rooting hard for
Michigan so I'll give you maybe the
spots weren't as gener generous as my
[__] Maze and gold eyes were Maze and
gold blue and Maze I'm [__] shot from
the game sorry
um Maze and gold
um but on those unnecessary roughnesses
I thought somewhere along the line that
they were going to even that up but
fortunately it didn't end up being a
factor and they [__] beat him and all
of a sudden we are literally one game
away I know we keep saying we I know
it's not my school but like um I have
friends who went there whatever had
family from out there but
um they could actually [__] win this
thing um we shall see but I heard uh
Washington has an unbelievable coach all
right this is the end of the football
podcast all right I got to stop with
this because I'm I'm I'm probably like
nobody's listening at this point as I
try to remember a game I literally just
[__] watched um all right Let's do
let's do your questions here for the
week
um a Christ do I have to turn my
goddamn thing back on no I don't all
right why Russell Wilson was
benched dear Bill
bikov Burr you talk briefly about
Russell Wilson's benching but you didn't
mention the real reason uh oh the real
reason a contract dispute well it's CU I
didn't know that and I don't have time
to watch sports the way I used to so
I'll I'll okay so it was a contract
dispute news broke that Bron 's
management actually approached Wilson
the day after he beat the Chiefs and
they told him they'd bench him for the
remainder of the season if he didn't
remove an injury Clause from his
contract well you shouldn't have [__]
signed it you can't [__] do
that so the Broncos are being [__] to
him basically the Clause says he will
receive 37 million guaranteed if he
can't pass his physical 5 days into the
next n NFL season Wilson later confirmed
that confirmed this news and explained
that he purposely had that Clause
written in because he's more injury
prone due to his age and style of play
well that was a smart move by him and
ownership shouldn't have signed
it I'm still on Russell's side here an
interesting side note is that the
reporter who broke the story is Jordan
Schultz son of Starbucks founder Howard
Schultz anyway I'm not a Russ Wilson fan
but the Broncos organization is shameful
for how they're treating him okay good
you agree they agreed to this contract
and it's highly inappropriate to pull
this move late in the season well yeah
that's what yeah that's how it works
like you can't do that as a player but
you know or as an artist but like the
the the the ownership or streaming
service or the studio yeah they they
hold all the cards they try to pull this
[__] uh anyway they agreed to this
contract and it's highly inappropriate
to pull this move this late uh late in
the season coach pton continues to say
publicly that he has no knowledge of
this contract stipulation and that the
benching is performance-based but that
seems like total horeshit given the news
and the fact that the benching was
threatened after he beat the Chiefs I
used to like
pton but he's been pretty classless ever
since he took his this latest job if you
remember he began his tenure by publicly
trashing his predecessor Nathaniel
hacket no I missed all of this on a
completely unrelated note just watched
old dads found it pretty entertaining
I'm glad glad you [__] raised your
eyebrows a little bit Dar it I
particularly liked all the cameos from
your friends like verie bartnik and
Steph toiv uh you're like a great value
version Adam Sandler I don't know what
that means Adam Sandler always gives you
great value um anyway anyway all the
best and go [__] yourself all right well
thank you I think you like the
movie pretty much liked it um all right
classic cars dear Billy blueballs sorry
you're married with two children right
no why would you say that uh big fan
from the hooky Lao in Massachusetts a
hooky
Lao wow that was in chapi I used to open
for
uh Allen Greer and Bobby Collins and all
these guys out there uh from the hooky
la
Massachusetts to the whu in Seattle I
don't know what that is you mentioned
dabbling in classic cars on your last
podcast as someone who has literally
been in the auto business since I was 12
now 71 I've done many times what you
describe which is basically buying a car
you can afford enjoying it by driving it
shows cruise nights then turning it over
it's fun and very AFF affordable uh I
know you have a young family in today's
economy believe me I'm doing great I'm
not even going to lie I'm doing better
than I ever thought I would be doing in
life but I appreciate that uh once you
get the hang of it you can actually make
money not much but at least it's not
always a money pit and therefore keep
upgrading as you go the best part for me
is the thrill of the hunt as soon as I
get my newest acquisition home I'm
looking for the next and almost always
only one at a
time hope you have fun with it the
rental idea sounds lame
peace um well the rental idea is a way
to [__] drive like 20 different cars
in 20
weeks um but I get it I wish you told me
the cars that you
had
um I'll tell you I I like
uh I don't know I just want something
with a stick shift too I kind of want
something like that and and I was
looking through some cars the other
night and I found one one of the ugliest
cars America ever made which was the
1978 Oldsmobile cutless which from the
front looks like it's a four-door sedan
for a businessman and in the back it
looked like a hatchback it's like if a
mullet was a car remember business in
the front party in the back this is kind
of what it was it was like this bizarre
attempt at making like a
Fastback and it was also I want to say
it was a four-door
sedan um which was really bizarre I even
think their 442 that year was a
four-door sedan you probably could get
it in two doors but
um just one of the uglier uglier cars
that the Chevy
citation and uh gotta have a third one
in
there I don't know just for lame
purposes the Mustang
2 um like most SE equal was not as good
as the first all right
Southwest giving fatties an extra seat
is not
okay I think it is then they're not
rubbing up against you and they got
plenty of places plenty of surface area
for their big fat
ass dear Bill last week you mentioned
that Southwest Airlines would give an
extra seat to overweight passengers as a
courtesy and that you were okay with it
you failed to realize the implication
for airline staff oh did I fail to
realize you failed to realize my opinion
on it [__] relax all right stop
talking to me like you're my [__]
boss you fail to
realize that implications the
implications for airline staff
especially
Pilots a large percentage of working
Airlines pilots pilots sorry get to
their origin airport V via commuting
from their home City they do this by
commuting uh via standby Aki AKA ride on
unsold
seats
um you well the [__] Airline should
buy him a seat that cheap [__] um if
the last available seat is given away to
an overweight person wow I love how you
just made that up this means that the
pilot who is simply trying to get to
work or get home will be denied boarding
and could ruin their entire
day um this is a
hypothetical and what you failed to
realize is that you don't run an airline
so you don't know you would have to call
Southwest and see if this is actually a
thing you just made this up you're going
Chicken Little on me imagine working a
4-day trip dealing with weather
maintenance ATC delays sleeping in dirty
hotels and AR arm pit cities is that
where they
sleep what are they Comics without a
following they're flying for a major
airline and the only thing getting you
through it is the fact you get to
celebrate your kids's birthday the day
you come back this like a [__]
Lifetime
movie uh you arrive at the
airport late in the day and speed walk
between terminals so you can make the
last light of the day home you show up
covered in sweat and the gate agent said
sorry sir we're full just give the last
seat to this
fatty you now have to get an Uber that
reeks like cigarettes to the country in
down the street and try again tomorrow
this is the
implication sincerely an airline pilot
all right well I guess I got trumped on
that um well I would say this your union
sucks most suck at this point I don't
know why um listen well maybe I failed
to realize that cuz I don't [__] fly
airplanes commercially you failed to
realize that when you say you fail to
realize to somebody and then use the
word implications that immediately
they're being talked down to and they're
not going to listen to what you have to
say but this is the new me this is the
new me in
2024 all right I got defensive had
nothing to do with you that's just my
childhood [__] issues
um well sir I got to tell you this I why
the [__] did Southwest Airlines stick
you in
shitty in shitty hotel rooms you know
why that is because corporations are a
[__] plague on society because every
quarter they have to make more
money and they cut cost anywhere that
they can and they just keep [__]
people over until we push back and at
some point you have to [__] push back
there's no [__] reason that an
airline pilot that has all those
lives you know in his or her hands
should be treated like that you should
be staying at a [__] fourstar
goddamn
Hotel they're just criminals because all
the money that they
save sticking you in that [__] Hotel
they just put in their own pocket they
don't give it to shareholders they don't
pass it on as you know a little bit
slightly cheaper
[__] um
airline tickets or
whatever all right well if I'm to
believe that person was actually an
airline pilot rather than somebody that
just hates fat people
um I want to say it's shocking that they
treat you that way but I am in the
entertainment business and I see the way
that they treat writers and actors and
all of that type of stuff they literally
don't want to pay
you um and all this new technology
that's coming out Ai and all of that
[__] is just it's not for us they're
going to make it seem oh this is going
to be this going to be great it isn't
it's for them it's for them so they they
will finally have a Workforce that won't
have rights and complain they want to go
back to slavery except this time they're
going to do with robots um how to handle
people driving too fast on your
street uh dear Billy pumpkin muff
bur my apologies to the airline pilot
all right I get into my own feelings
there you're 100% right I mean do it for
a [__] living all right
um they give him an extra
seat somebody on that board must have
like a fat wife or something why the
[__] would you I don't understand like
why would you now I'm on the other
side why don't why they should have to
pay for another seat
right I don't
know I will say though you
know even though you are an airline
pilot that whole [__] email that that
literally read like a made for TV
movie um like what was that movie with
the three
ghosts Chris
Kringle the night before Chris The
Nightmare on Elm Street the
night the night before Christmas eia
scrooge how to handle people just going
to give up how to handle people driving
too fast on your street dear Billy
pumpkin muff B not even pumpkin pubes
pumpkin
muff uh I'm hoping to get some
advice uh play the tune oh my God I
can't remember how it used to go it's
time for advice with your host
blyer and I'm
[__] with somebody else I can't
remember how that went I have a year and
a half old daughter and my wife and I
are starting to to get nervous about the
cars that speed down the street in front
of our house now that my daughter is
running around do you have any creative
and legal ideas to get cars to slow
down uh Merry belated Christmas hope you
have a Happy New Year and go [__]
yourself
um yeah I think the only way around that
is
uh you gotta somehow petition the city
for Speed
bumps um and then even then people do
that in between the two of them they
they're I don't know there some some the
way people drive sometimes it's because
they don't have kids they don't think
like that and they're also young and
it's just something about like being
young and going fast like you just you
don't have kids it's just it's just how
they're going to drive so you got to get
some speed I mean I drove like that when
I was a kid um you're just not thinking
cuz you're young young so um I have I
have I'm first of all I'm flattered that
you would think I would have an idea I
guess petitioning the city is probably
too
difficult
um I mean I don't know what to do that
took me back to a time when we used as
kids on trash
day one time we took uh like five trash
barrels and put him straight across the
street right around a blind turn and
then we went across the street and we
climbed this tree like right next
to right next to the trash
cans and it was also like that wasn't
dumb enough it was also the fall so like
the leaves were off the tree so there
was just like four five kids up in this
tree and this guy came around this is
the 70s came flying around the corner in
this big boat of a car and he locked him
up you know drum
braks and he gets out remember he's like
ah who's the wise guy I see you I see
you up in the trees you think this is
funny you can kill somebody you
know and what was funny was we didn't
say anything we were just looking at him
as he was yelling at us and we were just
you know hanging on like swinging in the
breeze and I do remember he put two on1
side and three on the
other and just got in his car and
[__] drove away um you can't do that
well back then there were also metal
trash cans too um yeah you can't do [__]
like that uh I would Google how to get
people to to slow
down you know you don't want to be that
guy out there going slow down because
all they do is give you the finger and
then they beep their horn at you and
then it makes you matter so
um I would just make sure my daughter
plays in the backyard and I would have a
fence um but I I feel your pain I
definitely feel your pain um I have
not I've chosen not to live places
because because my big you know actually
here's something for you if if you are
house hunting a major red flag is speed
bumps on your street that means people
cut through your street during rush hour
and also they're trying to take a
shortcut so they're going to be hauling
ass between the speed bumps there's also
going to be a lot of traffic on your
[__] Street
um you don't want [__] like that you
don't want sh you don't want that and
you don't want an
RV okay two major red flags an RV on
your block is not a good
sign
um yeah other than that check the water
pressure and [__] good luck to you
all right that's the podcast everybody
um happy New Year to everyone
congratulations to the Michigan world
Marines and the Washington Huskies I
missed the last minute and a half unless
something absolutely [__] crazy
happened uh should be a wild one next
Monday night and I can't believe
Michigan is one game away has not
won since
1997 and they've won a bunch of national
championships but most of them were
before Jackie
Robinson they only have one in the
modern era so I think it's time for them
to get two and it's going to be a great
one because I don't when was the last
time Washington Husky
won one if they've ever won one I can't
remember them remember them winning the
Rose Bowl when I was a kid but I don't
remember them ever winning one um all
right that is the podcast uh thank you
um for listening go [__] yourselves I
will check in you in on you on Thursday
I'm doing a fast people starting the day
starting the year three-day
fast um then to try to get in the best
shape I can at my age I'm done being a
[__] idiot uh um going to get my my
myself under control that's my goal here
uh for 2024 hope you guys have a happy
and a healthy one all right I'll see you
on Thursday wraps [__] fantastic and
I loaded in the grill with a buddy of
mine and had the thing [__] snug is a
bug in a rug there and uh had some
bungee [__] just for like coolers and
stuff I know people the bungees they
[__] move around with the weight of
the [__] goddamn beer they're not
goingon to I'm not going to be doing
Dukes of Hazard [__] so very excited
about that and uh my Ford F250 is got a
three-pronged outlet in the back and I'm
bringing my cappuccino maker so I'm
going to be [__] and I think I'm
bringing a toaster for the English
muffins I'm not doing that I'm GNA
[__] toast them up on the grill what
am I [__] Betty Crocker over here go
here with a bunch of appliances what are
you to do next bring an apron your
little [__] fairy there oh geez um so
I'm looking forward to the tailgate we
got uh we got egg sandwiches on English
muffins for breakfast we got burgers and
dogs nice and simple I'm going to have
cappuccinos uh the other guys are
bringing beers I'm drinking Waters uh
I'm making it in
time for uh the kickoff I'm rooting for
Michigan but it is an unbelievable honor
as a sports fan to watch these two great
schools go at it in a playoff
game in the granddaddy of them mall it's
Michigan versus Alabama and I'm going to
the [__] game and I still can't
believe it because my tickets are on my
phone which I still don't understand
like the amount of
apps that I had to download I had to go
to my email and accept the tickets then
I coming in you need a different [__]
app even though A Ticket Master you need
this [__] app and then that app tried
to take me to another app I had to call
my [__] web guy to try to get me
[__] through the whole thing I
finally have the
tickets um they're in my Apple wallet
which isn't really a wallet but they are
to
until that guy I mean the amount of
people that are going to lose their
phone being shitfaced out in that golf
course and not only are they going to
lose their phone they're going to lose
their [__]
tickets
um I mean we used to go and you would
get a ticket and then you just bought
the thing at the game and you put it
around your
[__] neck like like like the a
cowbell on a [__] cow and it was
impossible to lose although Joe bartnik
did do it one year he had it in his back
pocket and was absolutely [__] face and
uh we had to leave him behind like
Willam defo and [__] platoon but
that's a different story anyway uh this
is the end of the holidays I hope you
guys enjoyed your break I hope you
enjoyed time with your family friends
and all that type of [__] I hope you
avoided [__] [__] that even
though maybe they're related to or they
were friends that you don't need to deal
with them anymore and uh you know just
think in 2024 if you cut out all the
pain in the asses in your life how much
better your life would be yeah if
someone's a [__] a lot of work uh you
know make your life easier give yourself
less work
um yeah that's it that's what I got I'm
going to go to the game uh and thank you
guys for buying tickets to my show again
this year I know I always say this but I
uh can't tell you how much I appreciate
it how much it means to me and thank you
for listening to my podcast thank you
for watching old dads uh thank you for
watching Leo and all the specials great
specials that we put out at all things
comedy ATC uh that is it I'm looking
forward to another uh fun year of
standup uh out on the road and I've been
uh I have not been laying low I've been
hitting the clubs and I kind of got a
new 15 minutes that I'm [__] excited
about and uh that all kicks off the
weekend of the Super Bowl in Las Vegas
is when I start back out so starting off
with a uh a bang out in Vegas uh me and
verzy uh we're going to be doing
anything better live podcast out there
so if you're going to Vegas for the
Super Bowl please swing by and see us we
would love to have you and uh maybe one
of you guys can explain the prevent
defense to me maybe a football coach
will go to the game and and actually
give me numbers because it has to work
there's no [__] reason why these
people would be continuing to run this
thing Mike McCarthy doesn't want to get
fired these guys don't want to get fired
and they're still [__] doing it so it
has to on some level it has to work and
who the [__] am I I'm just some jerk off
comedian that [__] does [__] jokes
and talks about his dick on stage why
would I understand football at that
level um so they there you go that's
what I got there's your first [__]
there's your last 20 minutes of 2023
Happy New Year to all of you and I will
talk to you through the magic of editing
in two seconds after the Rose Bowl uh go
Blue